[Music]
tonight's Mega Millions jackpot is an
estimated annuitize four hundred and
fifty million dollars doing that jackpot
you must have to use five white balls
Plus that gold Mega Ball now let's see
if I can make you a millionaire tonight
it turned out Mega Millions drawing host
John Crowe was speaking to an audience
of one last week when the winning
numbers were drawn for one of the
lotteries biggest jackpots in history
the single winning ticket was sold here
at a 7-eleven in Port Richey Florida and
now we know who pulled that lucky ticket
the Florida Lottery says 20-year old
Shane Missler claimed his prize on
Friday Missler who says he is now
retired opted for the lump sum payment
of 281 million dollars he won after
buying five Quick Pick tickets with the
money he won from a scratch-off game
Missler says he wasn't surprised that he
won because he had a feeling that night
but you may not believe that when you
see what he posted on Facebook just a
few minutes after the drawing oh my god
retired mr. mister retired at the age of
20 that's one way to plan for your
retirement Jill Schlesinger the retired
mr. Mishler says he wants to help his
family have some fun and help humanity
with his money and I'd say hey I say he
has enough to do all those things he
does